you hit what you aim at if you try hard
enough and the education system has been
trying to demoralize people for 60 years
from Full Circle uh from the the idiocy
of AOC the depressing of what has
happened to Jen Z gen Z with these kids
at these college campuses putting out
statements in support of of Hamas uh
from that horrific rally that nazil
likee rally in Dearborn Michigan and BLM
and the stupidity of Andrew Tate all of
the stuff
maybe there's a way out of it and who
has explained a way out of it and gotten
more young people to deprogram
themselves than my good friend Jordan
Peterson well I think that if you set up
an education system that's designed to
do nothing but demoralize young people
and to convince them that their ambition
is dangerous and well even
world-threatening for that matter a
manifestation of patriarchal oppression
on the social front and then a danger to
the survival of the planet on the
natural front
then and you don't do anything to Foster
that ambition and to channel it into a
manner that might be productive and to
tell young people why their ambition
might be useful then you're going to get
exactly that so you hit what you aim at
if you try hard enough and the education
system has been trying to demoralize
people for 60 years then you think now
you have young people who are
demoralized ized and directionless while
they're never taught anything about how
to acquire a direction you know we did a
study I used this program I developed
called future authoring we did a study
where we had three studies actually
where we had University students sit
down essentially for 90 minutes 90
minutes this was it and write out a goal
a series of goals for their life right
who could they be in five years across
seven important dimensions of their life
and where might they be that would be
terrible if they didn't get their act
together we dropped their dropout rate
50% and raised their grade point average
30 by 35% three separate studies so
that's all you have to do if you want to
motivate young people is to teach them a
bit of visionary discipline and
encourage
it maybe that's what we got a double
down on right now maybe there are people
who are smart enough and bright enough
and brave enough to help lead us out of
this desert and to the promised land you
think that that's possible Right
otherwise we will all wander for a long
time time 40 years is a long time maybe
we don't have to do it for 40 years
right now but when you listen to someone
tell the truth and talk about how the
systems have failed all of the young
people right it's why every time I show
you one of these purple haired kids
scream or something it's like it's like
I'm not they're they're the victim of
this thing right these kids that are out
there these these gender queer kids that
don't know what is what they're that are
now supporting Hamas it's like they're
the tools they're the Rubes there's the
they're the Pawns in this game and we've
needed more and more people to stand up
and tell people what is right and that
is the ultimate irony related to our
mainstream media because the New York
Times put Jordan Peterson and me and a
bunch of Ben Shapiro and Milton Friedman
and a bunch of others on the front page
once not too long ago saying we were the
head of the alt-right the New York Times
did another piece on Jordan Peterson
front page about he was going for
enforced monogamy as if he wanted to
enslave the women uh enslave women the
way islamists do so the entire machine
has been designed to destroy all the
good people and push up all the bad
ideas thus we are
here